welcome back everyone to my round eat
recap from Buell in this one I play wgm
Juan Xian from China I do apologize if
I'm mispronouncing the name but my
opponent is over 2400 feet and uh hasn't
been super active in recent years but
have a lot of games for me to look over
and I decided before the game I would go
into an opening that I've never played
before and it's an opening I really only
learned this morning uh that opening
being the C3 Sicilian and the reason I
chose to play this was for a few reasons
for one I knew that there's no way she
would be preparing this before the game
given that I have I think no games in
the database as white in this position
and secondly I was inspired by none
other than Daniel nerdiski who I was
watching play a tournament in Charlotte
a few weeks ago and he played a really
nice line against uh Grandmaster Gian
Chao which seemed to go into very deep
Theory and I basically use that game as
a model for my opening preparation and
what I actually ended up doing was
compiling all of nerdinsky's chess.com
games into openingtree.com and looking
at his C3 cecilian repertoire I did a
similar approach a few days ago for a
different round when uh preparing Knight
F3 and E3 and looking at hikaru's games
but I thought it's a cool way to
basically learned an opening in a single
day and this morning I was scouring
through a lot of near Disney's games
seeing what he plays against various
lines in this opening and my opponent
played Knight F6 which I don't think
she's ever played before at least in a
recorded game I found two games where
she played D5 and this was a main line I
Was preparing but Knight F6 is
definitely a critical move and I think
it's the most popular move against the
C3 Sicilian and I did check this before
the game I played Pawn E5 Knight D5 and
Knight F3 and after Knight C6 I played
Bishop C4 and I was actually following
the game that nerdisky played against
John Chao and we still follow the game
after Knight B6 Bishop B3 it's all still
prep and nerdinski's game his opponent
played D5 after which takes takes was
played in my game D6 was played and I
knew that there's a potential
transposition I still take even if it's
not on passant my opponent takes back
and I castle and I did have this
position on my computer this morning and
while I was mainly preparing was if
black plays C4 there's an interesting
line Bishop C2 Bishop G4 Rook E1 and
Knight E5 and this is actually the game
between nerdesky and John Chao after
which Rook takes E5 was played and after
Bishop takes F3 Queen E1 and I Was
preparing a bit more deeply from here
but uh it seems like a line where white
can keep a small advantage and it's just
very tricky to given that black has to
choose where to put the bishop and the C
Pawn is a bit overextended there's ideas
later of B3 or Knight A3 or even in some
cases of A3 to harass a queen so I would
have been most comfortable going into
this but my opponent played a different
line instead of going for C4 she played
Bishop E6 and I was kind of hitting
myself during the game not physically
but more metaphorically because this
morning I was checking the database and
I knew this was a major line and I told
myself I would come back to check this
line after I looked at the other lines
in this variation but I never actually
ended up coming back to check Bishop E6
so unfortunately I was on my own in this
position
and yeah I really should have done a
little bit more work but this is the the
downside of trying to learn a completely
new opening right before the game is uh
I only had so much to cram right
beforehand now thankfully I still knew
some basic ideas in this position of
course with this C3 move light really
wants to get in D4 as quickly as
possible and I figured that I can play
D4 right away which I did and after she
takes I was still not in specific prep
but I knew an idea that very often white
doesn't have to take back immediately
and there's an alternative move here
Knight to A3 which I took a long time
calculating and I ended up playing given
that it looks like a nice way to keep
the position very tricky for black now
there's lines here where if black takes
on C3 then White's essentially gambling
a pawn but I thought this would be very
fun to go into I was planning to play
Knight to B5 hitting the queen and
essentially forcing the trade after
takes takes there's a lot of tension
still given the pawns are staring each
other the Bishops are staring each other
but black has to deal with a made-in-one
threat on C7 basically a triple Fork
mate so I was talking in the slime in
expecting that if we got into this black
would have to play Rook c8s and then I
could take take and take and if we got
to this position I think I'd be pretty
comfortable even though White's down a
pawn and queens are traded these pawns
are very ugly for black and very likely
I can win back at least one of the pawns
with a preferable position
but we didn't quite go into that because
after Knight A3 she played the move Pawn
Asics which I think is a very useful
prophylactic move simply preventing
Knight B5 because there are so many
lines where if black doesn't prevent
this move then Knight B5 gets a ton of
initiative for whites and in this
position I decided to trade I took on E6
first and after Queen takes I take on D4
with the Knight I didn't want to take
back with a pawn and leave myself with a
nice like Queen's Pawn so after takes I
take with queen and we reached a
position where I was feeling pretty good
given that I'm already castled and
Black's a little bit slow to develop the
king side especially with the queen
blocking the e-pawn epon blocking the
bishop g-pawn is pinned by the queen on
D4 so it seems like white has a nice
advantage in this position but the
advantage is only temporary and
depending on how next several moves go
if that can complete development in
Castle then it should probably be equal
so the next several moves are I think
very critical and she started with Rook
d8 posing the question where I should
put my queen I decided to play Queen H4
getting out the way but still I think
this is a useful swear given that if
black ever plays G6 there's ideas of
Bishop H6 and if black plays Queen F6
offering the queen trade I would have
Bishop G5 with tempo
so here she played Queen C6 and now
Black's plan is very clear of playing E6
and developing the bishop and castling
as soon as possible
so I took a lot of time in this position
trying to figure out the best approach
to try and slow down Black's development
and also just try and make threats in
the position
and the move I wanted to play was Bishop
E7 which would prevent the epon from
moving but I rejected this move because
I wasn't sure about F6 just kicking my
bishop and even though it seems like an
accomplishment to provoke F6 if I play
Bishop E3 back and then E5 it just seems
like black is doing okay here and I
didn't see any clear way to kind of
disrupt Black's development of Bishop D6
and castling or Bishop E7 and castling
so I decided to play Bishop E3
immediately with idea that after E6 I
take on B6
and at first this looks like I'm not
really achieving much I'm just
simplifying props in Black's favor but
the idea is after Queen takes I have
Queen A4 check and I'm really trying to
keep the initiative and keep the
pressure
and what I was hoping for is if she
plays Queen C6 offering a queen trade I
would happily trade queens and then get
an end game where my knight comes to C4
and I'd eventually play Rook D1 I think
white is significantly better here even
though it's equal material I think the
Knight is just much better than the
bishop and black is left with these
long-term weaknesses on the queen side
two isolated Pawns so this didn't quite
happen because she didn't play Queen C6
and instead she played Rook D7 which at
first maybe looks very uncomfortable for
black essentially self-pinning and now
the king is tied down to defending the
Rook
but um it's not so easy for white to
exploit the pin and in the game I did my
best I played Rook to D1 of course
threatening The Rook she defended and
then I played Rook D3 preparing the
double up and it seems very close to
being very good for whites but she has
us move Bishop to D6 essentially
relieving all the pressure on the D file
and getting ready to Castle next move
and I didn't see anything better than
what I played in the game uh Rook D1 she
castled and now black is threatening to
take on H2 so I played G3 and then she
played what I think is a very precise
move Rook D to d8 and maybe it seems
more natural to play Rook fd8 but then
the bishop would still be pinned to the
D7 Rook so after Rook dd8 the plan for
Bach is to play Bishop E7 or Bishop C5
and then just neutralize the D file and
at this point it really just felt like
my advantage has completely
evaporated I'm not sure if I was even
that much better during the game but
what ended up happening was I played
Knight C4 she played Bishop C5 and I
traded Rooks
and played Queen C2 and offer the draw
and she accepted it and the game ended
very peacefully uh not not too much
fireworks towards the end but I think it
was a pretty clean game and if we check
with the engine this game we do have
kind of a special occurrence that
neither of us made any
inaccuracies mistakes or blunders
according to leeches stockfish it was a
perfect game by both of us although
maybe there were some moments that could
have been improved maybe very slight
improvements for example I think after
Bishop C5 I did have this McQueen A5
which the engine seems to like although
it didn't even cross my mind it just
seemed like a weird uh weird idea for
the queen
so I really can't be too upset with this
game I was happy with opening
preparation it's always nice to employ a
new weapon and to surprise the opponent
early but I think she handled the
opening very well and played very
accurately to neutralize my activity in
the early middle game
so this puts me at four and a half out
of eight points this is my second draw
in a row against a high rated player so
really no complaints I think my last two
games have been very very clean on my
part so hopefully I can continue the
clean play going into tomorrow uh
tomorrow will be the penultimate game
and I am a little bit behind with
recording the Recaps so I'm not sure
which day this will be posted but do
stay tuned for more chess and yeah I'll
see you guys in the next recap